but it's difficult to avoid this because
many of these questions or almost all of
them are directed toward me so how can i
answer them without speaking my personal
experience and at the same time i am
guided by
a screenwriting adage which says that
the more personal the pain the more
general it is which means that the more
specific you can get with being
wholeheartedly open the more
people
resonate with it rather than staying at
a superficial
high level
that's actually one of the guiding
principles of the podcast itself that's
one of the reasons why i try to get into
as
much
meticulous technicalities as i possibly
can because that's what i would like to
know and i imagine that the audience is
more engaged the more i'm engaged even
if
sometimes
some of the terminology goes over some
of the people's heads not all the people
the this podcast tends to have a huge
a huge following of extremely bright
people brighter than myself
and that's extremely
flattering
if i seem nervous it is because i am i
am nervous i'm not comfortable speaking
about myself
if i'm darting my eyes around it's
because i'm thinking i can give you some
background as to how the podcast is run
i get
notes about my furrowed brows and i'm
constantly
looking as if i'm angry and i'm not
angry my wife even comes to me at times
and i have to bark at her i feel bad
because she thinks i'm angry but i'm
thinking and i'm in such such deep
thought stacked upon one another as soon
as she comes to me said babe are you
okay
i'm thinking i'm if i'm mad i'll let you
know if i'm mad don't bother me i'm
speaking somewhat quietly because she's
sleeping in the next room
okay akash 1996 asks tell us something
about yourself who are you what is your
science background when and why did you
start your youtube channel what are your
aims what are your dreams in general
general okay so that's quite a few
questions man
akash it's a great thing that your name
starts with an a because i sorted this
by alphabetical
i sorted this alphabetically by username
and this will serve as an introduction
to
myself into the channel so who am i well
i'm kurt jaymungal
as to who am i
you know
there's a greek
phrase called know thyself its origins
are greek
john vervicky said
to know thyself isn't what most people
in the western world thinks it means to
know thyself which we think it means
let's have a scrapbook and post our
memories
that's not what it means it means to
under to understand the operating system
by which you
run
and i don't i don't know mine i'm
tempted to give an itemized biography
i'm tempted to state my ethnicity and my
job and so on but i don't think that
is what i should identify with and i'm
wary of saying
i am so-and-so because unconsciously
i'll identify with it and that's part of
my issue with the whole
political discourse right now is that
people tend to be identifying with
aspects of themselves that they
shouldn't see as a paramount part of
their personality so as for who am i man
like i'm i don't know and i'm figuring
that out sorry akash what is your
science background it's math and physics
particularly something called
high energy physics which is more in the
theoretical end i'm not concerned i'm
wholly unconcerned with the practical
end of physics
i even told nathan miravold i'm more
comfortable with fibrobundles than i am
with bernoulli's equation
and that's absolutely true
i'm concerned with something called
general relativity and quantum field
theory and merging them now some people
think you'll hear this spout it off
plenty that quantum field theory people
will say quantum mechanics but it's
technically quantum field theory and
general relativity can't be merged they
can
easily
fairly easily in low energy limits it's
just in high energies that you have
problems so i'm interested in the high
energy or
in other words low
distance because high energy means low
distance
the high energy and low distance merging
of general general relativity and
quantum mechanics
when and why did i start my youtube
channel
well when and why when depends on what
constitutes this youtube channel so
in many ways it could be with the gnome
interview so that's about a year and a
half ago
in many ways my channel started with
brian keating which is about 10 months
ago brian keating was the first
interview that i did that was
non-political that was just about math
and physics because at the time i was
i started this channel called better
left unsaid for a film which is
releasing tomorrow by the way this is
promotion for it
i have a film that i directed called
better left unsaid a documentary about
when does the political left to go too
far and it has nothing to do with me
accepting the right even though people
see the absence of
of the right the quote unquote political
right in the tagline as me
admitting that they're correct in some
manner that's not the case in fact if
you watch the film you'll see that i
talk about the extreme right as well as
the extreme left
this channel was interviews for that and
then i pivoted because i thought well
now that the film is done which the film
has been done for almost a year why not
go back to my
original
interest of
math and physics
so i did with brian keating and brian
keating has a great channel a channel is
extremely similar to mine so i curse him
for that but it's great because we have
a revolving door of guests if you like
his guests you like mine and vice versa
i'll leave his descript i'll leave his
channel in the description you should
subscribe to it if you like this you'll
most likely like brian keating's perhaps
even more
so in some ways channel started one and
a half years ago with noam or 10 months
ago with brian keating but in another
way the channel truly started
eight months ago or nine months ago with
donald hoffman once i interviewed donald
hoffman it was almost as if toe or
theories of everything became its own
genre some people in the audience say
that there's no channel like it
and
while that's flattering i don't know how
much of that is true i hope it's true
that's pretty cool if it's true i don't
see myself as having a particularly
different interview style other than
going into some of the abstruse
mechanics but other than that i don't
see it as particularly inventive or
particular
what are my aims and my dreams okay aims
and dreams
well
by the way if you see me speak with
haste or rapidity it's because i am
trying to get through this fairly
quickly
my dreams
my aims at least with this channel and
at least with the next few years of my
life is to clarify my thinking and
develop what's called a veltan shaoong
it's a german word which means an
all-encompassing worldview or framework
through which to interpret the world
it's it's to call it a worldview is to
minimize it
now you by the way you can think of a
veltan xiaowung as a theory of
everything in the psychological sense
not in the physics sense though it does
include the physics sense for me veltan
xiaowung is the word
velt if you ever hear the word v or the
letter v
in a german word it's w
the other aim for this channel to answer
akash's question i'm only on question
number one to answer akasha's question
is that there
is a part of me that thinks
coming up with a theory of everything
the way it's traditionally done is with
private practice of erudite individuals
in
academia
and i'm unsure if innovation is to be
found there anymore
that's false
there's plenty of innovation coming from
the universities especially in the stem
fields what i mean is
i think that there's
vast swathes
missing
from our
current theories of everything and i
think that it's a
i'm hoping that what i can do is make
this a community effort that people from
the outside can watch and contribute
who are who didn't necessarily have the
chance to go to university or aren't
trained mathematically
and collectively sometimes though i
despise
the word collectively because of how
it's been co-opted but collectively we
can come up with
or at least advance a theory of
everything so that's a goal of this
channel that's a dream a dream of mine
all right let's get to the next one
account number one says what are your
thoughts on rupert spira advice
invitevent
vedanta and thanks for making such an
awesome podcast now
account number one you can see by the
fact that i'm struggling to pronounce
vedanta
that i'm unfamiliar with it i know a
tiny amount like a modicum about it and
i know a modicum about rupert spira
though i do have an interview with him
booked june
15th or so which means it'll go online
june at the end of june
oh they also say thank you for making
such an awesome podcast i don't like to
read the plaudits but i'll do so because
it's part of the question and it also
it's endearing
thank you account number one
account number one has another question
what or how do you think about abstract
mathematical structures philosophically
okay i'm not quite sure i understand
what you mean when you say how do i
think of them
philosophically
i imagine what you mean is
am i a platonist or non-platonist
that's all i can think of unless what
you mean is am i algebraic or am i
analytical or geometrical or visual i'd
say i'm minorly visual and a majorly
algebraic
and majorly conceptual so that means
that
i don't know how to describe the
conceptual one because i haven't heard
many people talk about it it's more like
i think in terms of concepts that are
nebulous or nubilis and then they relate
as for
platonism i don't see how mathematical
truths can be invented i don't see it as
being dependent on us though lee smolin
makes a case that they're time dependent
this means that i'm
i'm not sure the answer is i'm not sure
and i'm tilted toward platonism
you can think of it as i'm platonically
dating platonism this comes from account
number two
kurt have you considered getting douglas
hofstetter on the show the answer is
every day
alex broman says what's the role that i
see psychedelics having in our society
for the next 20 years and then he says
good job with a peace sign
medically it seems to be efficacious it
seems to be more so than traditional
medications
and treatments
as for individuals i hope
i hope it's a force for good it's
it's it's
well
they it's
they can be
world shattering let's say that and that
can be for good or for ill
alexander 96 says you seem to be a gamer
at least you've mentioned excitedly
games when talking to other people so
what games do you like what games have
you played in the past and any thoughts
on the value of video games
personally i'm certain that dark souls a
pretty challenging game if you don't
know it has strongly conditioned me to
enjoy
more difficult challenges okay so this
person is extremely perceptive
alexander
i love dark souls i love demon souls i
love from software games in general i
love fallout i love single-player wide
open sprawling vistas and
missions and rpgs i love those i love
those two bits i i'm extremely looking
forward to playing this game called
disco eliseum or ellis iom
elysium i believe disco elysium
though i
i played it for about an hour
i don't get time to play video games man
i'm just
studying for this podcast almost all the
time
i wish i had more time to play because i
love playing video games
i dislike shooters
although i do like some mindless games
games that i could listen to a podcast
or do some research that just require
auditory input
while i play
but i don't like them in the sense that
i enjoy playing those games it's more
like okay now i get to listen to this
book that i have to read
or research this person and at least i
can play a video game maybe get a trophy
or two at the same time disco eliseum
there seems to be elements of one
psychological state speaking to oneself
and that's alarming to me
i won't rehash why you can watch the ian
mcgillcrest video
to find out why
i just hope it doesn't induce something
like psychosis
i don't know if i can handle that game
metal gear solid i love the series metal
gear solid
metal gear solid 5 though i was
extremely disappointed i think everyone
was the gameplay in it is great but the
it's not what i was looking for in a
hideo kojima game
i love indie games
indie games that play with mechanisms
sorry mechanics gameplay mechanics
inventively
i'm one of those rare people that find
metal gear solid 4 to be peerless i
actually think it's the best of all the
metal gear solids even though
even though it's lacking in terms of
the
intricacies of metal gear solid three
in terms of fan service it was wonderful
if you're a fan of metal gear solid from
one two three you're
i don't know how you can't love metal
gear solid 4.
someone said rebecca says why am i
wasting my life with video games instead
of experiencing the earth well that
one can say why are you telling stories
instead of experiencing the earth in
some way the stories inform how you
experience the earth and in some ways
a video game is a more interactive story
it depends on if you're using it to
escape the earth
and also video games are part of the
earth where am i from daniela daniela
wants to know i'm from trinidad i
believe someone asks that
later
i also have an idea for video game which
at some point
because i don't like
these games that have speech checks and
then
sneaking options or kill options those
are just three and then they think well
look i've spanned the gamut of all you
can do with the video game look how
wonderful in options my rpg is i don't
think that's
all there is i like more than that i
have an idea but i may have to lay it to
the side along with the multiplicity of
other forlorn ideas of mine amidu camara
says what ism of consciousness do i lean
most toward
and what are my thoughts on the bizarre
phenomenon of
alien abductions well okay as for the
ism that i lean toward
i would say none yet
as for alien abductions i don't know
what to make of it i don't think that
everyone who
claims that they've been abducted are
asinine or lying
i also don't think the same about
bigfoot and i would like i would love to
get
less drought on the podcast i keep
reaching out to his
people and they keep putting me off they
keep saying six months from now or five
months from now
hopefully at some point lestrade will
come on the podcast i would love to talk
to him that's survivorman for those of
you who are unacquainted
i do have an intimation as to why ufos
and bigfoot and other phenomenon might
exist
as well as an explanation for why
they're mysterious
but it may be imbecilic so i don't
i won't state it because it's not well
formed
it's just that i don't i don't know it i
find it odd that bigfoot hasn't been
captured by any camera
some people will claim it has been okay
anna lucas anna luco lukomski anna
lakomsky says
by the way if i'm appearing tired i am
for the past couple nights i haven't
gotten much sleep groggy so i'm in the
midst of that
okay let's see
anna lukomski says i would love to hear
the story behind your podcast and how
you became inspired to do a podcast on
toes on theories of everything the
practicalities of how you actually
managed to get it going especially the
story behind how you got your first
guest i wonder if you knew how much that
moment would change your world
theories of everything
theories of everything that is this
channel was an evolution it started as
blue that is better left unsaid i call
it blue so if you ever ever hear me use
the word blue i'm referring to better
left unsaid which is a documentary i
directed which is releasing tomorrow and
again
quick promotion if you want to buy it
please get it from
betterleftunsaidfilm.com don't buy it
from itunes and so on because
betterleftonsetfilm.com will have the
director's version which is the much
longer ponderous philosophical
psychological version that
contains elements the public won't
necessarily like but if you're a fan of
this channel you'll probably like
and that one you get it for free on the
better left unsaid film.com when you buy
the regular version it just you get a
choice do you want to watch the regular
or the director's cut which is two hours
long so a half hour of extra material
as for
the first guest it depends on what
qualifies this channel the first guest
in many ways was gnome or in many ways
it was brian keating or in many ways it
was donald hoffman
now the hoffman interview was one that i
had no idea would change me as much as
it did not because of his theories per
se but because
it seems like as soon as i released that
podcast it was as if toe theories of
everything became his own genre
and
that
was exciting
because it was me talking to someone the
way that i would like to talk to them
instead of
somewhat of a facade of an interviewer
journalist type person
which characterized the previous
interviews which i've now unlisted
because i
am embarrassed about them and they don't
fit the theme of this channel so
donald hoffman
and the reception to it indicated to me
that
i was on an interesting past path and it
spurred me on
apostolos prel
says
do you have a facebook page for your
youtube audience
sorry do you have a facebook page for
your youtube channel and i want to
support you kurt so i don't have a
facebook page not for this channel at
least
and if you want to support then
please support on patreon
it
patreon genuinely helps each dollar
helps and you may not think so but
it helps because it's completely
voluntary it's
someone voluntarily is giving me a
dollar or 10 or whatever it may be per
month
continually
it
financially it's it's a boon
i tell my wife each time i get an email
from a patron and i also personally
email each patron they think that it's a
form letter because they're usually
surprised that
they get a personal communication but
i'm genuinely happy my wife and i
we're delighted each time
it also serves the amount of patrons i
have also serves as a
metric of the positive response to this
channel beyond the adulatory
comments because some of these comments
they're extremely flattering but at the
same time
i look at other channels i'm sure if
anyone here is a content creator you've
experienced this where someone says i
love this this was the best podcast or
this was the best video and then you
watch some other video of a
of a cat
hitting a dog and then the dog
being happy about it and then someone
says this is the best video i've ever
seen online and then you wonder okay i
was happy about my comment at first but
then
that also gets the same attribution
so there's a temporary ego boost i get
but then a subsequent deflation of it
however
the patreon subscribers definitely
indicate to me that someone's willing to
say that this is something they see
worth supporting a mission that they can
believe in and they do with their with
their dollar so i'm delighted and i find
it truly touching thank you
aspen french says i want i'm a fan of
your content kurt but i'm also a
feminist and i try to listen to the
opposition and so on
but this was on the janice fiamango
interview
but i was extremely frustrated by this
discussion
there's not
well what i want to ask is
would you consider a voice from the
other side and answers absolutely i am
actively looking for people who are on
the more
radical left end who espoused critical
race theory and
our black lives matter supporters and so
on
whatever you think of as the typical
left extreme left-leaning whatever you
want to call it i'm not disparaging it
but those types of people i'm definitely
looking for in fact for the documentary
better left unsaid i reached out at
least initially to way more people
professors on the left than i did on the
right and i got no after no after no
after no after no
it was only people who were on the
center
center left center right who actually
said yes to me but i'm looking for
people i have a whole
document of questions for
hoping that someone eventually will come
online and speak with me hopefully a
professor i don't want just some postdoc
or it could be a postdoc i don't want
some undergrad or recent graduate to
talk to me or just someone who says that
i'm a trans person and you should talk
to me well i would prefer a professor
for various reasons
austin harper says do you believe in
free will
are aliens here god
question mark is ego death real death
what is the perfect form of government
assuming there is one why does life have
symmetry but physics is having issues
with it
do you think black holes have
singularities what about pan psychism
i've subbed since your sabine interviews
that is the
sabine hostenfelder interview
so basically you're required to answer
at least one of these questions okay do
you believe in free will i'm not sure
there are arguments for it and there are
arguments against it and
i don't know there's definitely the
feeling that free will exists and
there's definitely the feeling that your
your feeling of free will is illusory
that is during meditation or a
psychedelic experience let's say or even
a hypnagogic near dream state
as for our aliens here i'm not sure as
for god not sure as for his ego death
real death
that's a
terrifying question
that's a terrifying question
well that's an extremely extremely
extremely terrifying question man i
it's so it's a it's such a terrible
question i i have to move on from that
question
what is what is the perfect form of
government assuming there is one so it
might be that there's none it might be
god's government or it might be one
that's dependent on on time or it might
be one where you maximize
voluntary choice but then you get into
the issue of what constitutes voluntary
choice is it positive freedom or is it
negative freedom
which means you get into the
base of philosophy and i see that many
of the arguments about capitalism versus
socialism
or communism in fact
are arguments not about which political
system is correct but which
philosophical strain do we use to
interpret freedom
i see it as a debate between freedoms
rather than
political which means it's a
philosophical debate
as for it
why does life have symmetries but
physics doesn't i don't think physics
has an issue with symmetries in fact i
would say life has an issue with it
so i don't i disregard the question do i
think black holes have singularities i
don't i don't know
they may they may not pan psychism hmm
pan psychism may be true maybe true in
some strange way that we don't
conceptualize currently
now hopefully
austin harper hopefully i've answered
your question somewhat
although i assume not copacetically
babic rastal
i can't pronounce your last name
it says what have you learned from the
many brilliant people you have
interviewed that has affected your
day-to-day life and what are the
practical changes that i see day-to-day
each one each interview has influenced
me
though
to say specifically how would require me
to dredge the influence from the depths
and often that requires sufficient
reflection which i haven't been able to
do at least not for this ama
what's influenced me most
okay well that one at least recently is
ian mcgillcrist
let's say
well it's world view shattering that's
for sure it has me second guessing
almost all my thoughts
and actions
more so than usual which we're already
at brobdingnaggy in proportions to use
a word that i
like
beerus attitude says after interviewing
all these brilliant people and educating
yourself on so many topics do you see
the world clearly more clearly or are
you lost now i'd say beers that i'm
much more lost
although simultaneously i do see the
world
more clearly now the way that i i've
been thinking about this for a while and
the best i could do is come up with an
analogy
okay so the analogy looks like this
imagine that you're a swimmer and you're
you're you can't see the top you don't
know where the surface is
and you're aiming for the surface you
want to get out
you don't know how far below you are so
you estimate you have some gut your you
have some intuition you have you have a
hunch and you say i think i'm 200 meters
below the surface i think the surface is
200 meters up let's say and you have a
flashlight at the same time which can
see
50 meters
ahead so that's like your clarity you
can see a certain amount of head but
then you also have an estimation as to
how much farther along are you
well i would say that
what's happened with each interview i'm
swimming upward so i'm making progress
that is
well i'm making progress but
my estimation as to how far
the surface is keeps increasing so
whereas last year or two years ago it
would have been 200 meters up now it's a
kilometer up so a thousand meters up
but my flashlight has also gotten more
powerful so my flashlight can now see
100 meters up so that's like my clarity
has increased and i've seen that i've
made some progress
but at the same time i'm much farther
along i mean sorry much i have much
farther to go than i thought
so it's a strange
mix of
both clarity and
i wouldn't say confusion but
but being lost boris martinez says i see
you're a man with a talent for figures
and i wonder what is your iq what is
your age and net worth
three simply yet meaningful numbers of
course feel free to send me to hell with
my impertinent
questions okay for iq
i
when i was a teenager i did a few tests
i
got obsessed with them for a couple
weeks
and i i did a gamut of tests
the
score that i
that i had most frequently was around
the high 150s
and the
the lowest score that i achieved was in
the high 120s and the highest score that
i achieved was in the low 200s so
take that
for what it's worth it could be anywhere
from 120
high 120s to low 200 likely it's around
or likely it was around the high 150s
though
it
has drastically decreased because well
turning to the next question
my age is 32 turning 33
and your iq
steadily decreases from 18 to 24 onward
and some of these iq tests were the
ravens progressive matrices test so i do
have some faith in them but at the same
time they weren't official though i was
officially tested by an adhd clinic
because
i was tested for adhd and i apparently
do have it but first the way that this
clinic works is they have to make sure
that they separate people from
those who can't
stay focused because they're simply
slow-minded let's say
in other words having a low iq or those
who have a functioning iq and can't
focus and they need to make sure you're
in that group before they diagnose you
with adhd so they did a battery of
cognitive tests for me and i remember
that i either scored perfect or scored
one away from perfect
there were some verbal tests that is
what is the definition of so-and-so word
there were some
mathematical tests now that should be a
breeze for me because hopefully i'm
trained mathematically i mean i should
be if i got a degree in it
and
there was some physical manipulation
puzzles
i remember
and i think
that one i didn't i either scored
correctly at the last second like there
was a timer or
i just missed it by one second i don't
recall which one but either way
as for my net worth my net worth is
disappointing this guy said that
i asked him
i believe his name is boris boris martin
is boris what do you think my net worth
is before i answer this question on an
ama and he said
he thinks it's a half a million usd to
1.5 million usd and like
that would be
well
it's much much much less in many ways
what i'm doing is extremely
irresponsible by putting youtube videos
out because i should be
working toward building my net worth
especially considering i'm thinking of
having a kid at some point but my net
worth is
less than a tenth of what he thinks it
is
so there
as for
the earnings of this podcast per month
it's something like one thousand dollars
and that seems like
plenty to some people and nothing to
others it depends on where you live
where i live it's almost nothing because
the rent is already two thousand dollars
per month
and not and the one thousand dollars
doesn't even go directly toward me it
goes toward indie film theo which is a
company that i have as a non-profit
because technically we're incubating
this theories of everything channel as
well as my documentary and so on so what
i'm doing is extremely irresponsible but
i see the
the growth monetary growth and
i also believe wholeheartedly in what
i'm doing and i'm much more
fulfilled
and
excited almost each day to wake up and
get started on studying for new guests
and to talk to some of the community as
well
so i'm
at least temporarily being
foolish and
pursuing this rather than
an accumulation of wealth
brent okay i'll take some questions from
the audience right now if i'm ignoring
your question it's because i'm reading
the questions that have been given to me
from a few weeks ago there are quite a
few comments please oh roon thorson
thank you so much for donating
have you considered space being a
literal movie stage
i don't know what it i'm sorry roon i
don't know what you mean by literal
movie stage i'm a filmmaker
and
i would say we use our movie stage
in space so it'd be strange if space was
a movie stage i don't
i don't know how to understand that
question
boxers are briefs boxers
stefan the current status of better left
unsaid is that it's complete it's
releasing tomorrow
please visit
betterleftonsaidfilm.com if you want to
buy better left unsaid because then you
will get the director's version anna
likomsky says is my toe for is my quest
for toe spiritual or scientific i'd say
it's both and i don't see why they need
to be different and perhaps they're both
the same in their extreme perhaps
something i'm thinking about is what is
science 2.0 this is something you may
hear me talk about quite frequently at
least
starting soon
it's a project of mine
think about this science started
from pre-science that is from alchemy
and
observation rather than experimentation
that was aristotle
and then it became science so then that
means there's a trajectory so then i'm
wondering well what the heck does that
mean for where it can go
what does science 2.0 look like does it
mean it just explains more phenomenon
what does it mean to explain
rebecca says that she loved the tammy
peterson interview thank you rebecca i
appreciate it
making sense says we're investing in
your growth man thank you so much you
definitely are investing in my growth
and i appreciate it and hopefully
in some small way
i'm investing in yours
would i like god to be a reality
that's a tough question rebecca i can't
answer that
brandon sp says do you think philosophy
should be more crucially
in stem
that's interesting
see
the people of this channel
sorry that is you who are watching
you're likely extremely high in openness
extremely high otherwise you wouldn't be
on this channel and people who are high
in openness and high in intellect tend
to think that everyone else should
operate in the same way that they do and
i don't think so i don't think that
everyone should be guided by philosophy
i don't think it interests them i don't
think that it's useful for them at all
and
i
i despise when
you'll hear me never
or seldom i don't like to use the word
never you'll hear me almost never say
the word
stupid
to describe people of low iq and that's
because
i don't
i don't think there's anything wrong
with people with low iq and i
i see it as a
an arrogance of people who are
intellectual to look down at people who
are less intellectual than them
at the same time they need them to run
their companies so they despise them yet
they need them which means you you don't
like the people that you cooperate with
which means you don't like humanity in
some respect also iq is heavily
hereditary
that means that
calling someone stupid which to me is an
ethically thick word
which means that it comes with a
descriptive
a description and a connotation so the
description is you have a low iq but the
the connotation is that you're inferior
because of it it's almost like the n
word there's the description you're a
black person but then there's the
connotation it's that you're inferior
and i'm insulting you
the word stupid is like that and i don't
like that word stupid i don't i
i wish that intellectuals wouldn't use
that word
because it firstly makes people with low
iq feel horrible about themselves and
they can't necessarily help it because
like i mentioned
the research indicates that iq is
extremely inveterate it's
it's like your ethnicity it's something
you can't
change though you can harm it you can
reduce it
and so it's like being racist to me if
someone says you're stupid that's like
it's the same it should be considered to
be the same as being racist
anyway brandon to answer your question
about do i think philosophy should
feature more crucially in stem education
i don't
think so necessarily because i don't
think it's for everyone though i need to
think more about that question brandon
sp you also have another question what
is your intuition as to the weirdness of
a theory of everything that would have
to be there for it to be the real deal
any ideas as to its form compared to
current conceptions of physics i think
at a minimum it should unify general
relativity and quantum field theory i
think at a minimum it should do that i
think that there may be more forces than
just the four that we know i think
space-time isn't as simple as
or may not be as simple as a pseudo
romanian four manifold i think it may be
more strange than just that
i think consciousness may have
some integral part to play
and i'm not saying this in any hokey or
quote-unquote woo-woo manner because
nema arkani hamed and even edwin have
espoused similar sentiments though i
can't find the exact quotation
i've looked for the edwitten one
nima though nima did say that he thinks
consciousness may have something to do
with the collapse of the wave function
and the reason he gives is
it's a great one he says penrose thinks
so and penrose isn't an idiot and i
don't and
well that's basically the argument
nima is one of the brightest physicists
in the world by the way i also think
that an understanding as to the origins
of the universe is necessary for a toe
for a theory of everything so those are
those are five elements that is
unifying
quantum field theory with general
relativity i think that there may be
more forces this is not necessary i'm
surmising and then
space-time is
more intricate than a simple
pseudo-rimanian four manifold
that consciousness may
have a paramount role and that i believe
it has to do with the origins of the
universe bubble puppy says have you
tried to get bob lazar on so yes i've
tried to get bob lazar on i
don't want to use jeremy corvell
or corbell as a contact because it's
off-putting to use some of your
interviewees to get other interviewees
but i have no idea of how to contact bob
and i think that
bob lazar is uninterested in speaking
which is why i would love to just talk
to him about physics
phillip
phillip thank you so much
i appreciate it philip
strenstrom
asked a question and it
i believe it'll come up
yeah okay so graeme
josh says jos
please
excuse me if i'm mispronouncing your
name
graham jose says kurt what do you plan
on doing with the knowledge you're
collecting is there a synthesis coming
well
see there are different kinds of
mathematicians they're the kinds of
mathematics and i'm not a mathematician
but
let me go down this route there are some
mathematicians who are great at the
details and there's some mathematicians
who are great at overviews now i
i would say i i'm more esm plastic in
the sense that i'm much more interested
in unifying disparate fields and
principles and i ha i seem to have a
knack for that this is one of the
reasons why i'm
interviewing as many variegated
intellectuals as i possibly can then
i'll assemble so yes there is a
synthesis coming it's not coming
only from me but
hopefully from you all as well we have a
discord and people talk there
and i do read it i don't get the chance
to read them all all the time but
oh yes at some point here's what i would
like to do this is an announcement i
would like to get some people who are
audience members that have their own toe
their own theory of everything to come
on the toe clippings channel which will
have a link in the description i think
it already does if not you can find it
search toe clippings and youtube it's a
channel of the clips from this channel
and i want them to live stream because i
don't have the time always to go through
it takes me quite some time to go
through someone's corpus of work it
would be great if what would happen is i
get two people who two audience members
who have tolls and i say hey you want to
be talked about on this channel and i
would like you to be talked about as
well but i don't have the time to go
through your entire theory so why don't
you learn this person's theory and this
person learn this person's theory and
battle it out on a live stream with me
moderating this way
there's something called theomaki which
is battle of the gods and i tend to like
that that's one of the reasons why i
think people find debates to be
nourishing and
pre-possessing it's because you're
seeing people who are
giants fight to the best of their
ability and then you learn often much
more than if they were to simply present
their work in a lecture daniel says how
have your views on marxism evolved since
starting this channel well again
for those who are watching not to turn
this into a complete promotion for
better left unsaid but i have a
documentary called better left unsaid
which is about when does the left go too
far the
political left
the reason is that it's extremely easy
to identify when the right goes too far
because one might
co-locate them with racists and
bigots and so on and they seem to
overtly
state that
whereas on the left it's more
philosophical which
you can read as that being my domain i
like philosophy now that that's out of
the way the person wants to know how
have my views on marxism evolved
my views have changed to become more
perplexed by anyone who is staunched in
thinking that marxism is correct or
if they think socialism is correct or
socialism is de facto wrong it's it's
it's just extremely difficult to
these these concepts these
firstly there's no consensus as to what
marxism is there's no consensus as to
what socialism is there's no consensus
as to what capitalism is though there
seems to be a little bit more of a
consensus there
and so when someone says capitalism is
absolutely correct
or socialism is absolutely correct it
tells me more about their predilection
to adherence of a particular
handed down doctrine than it does tell
me about their
then it does tell me about the doctrine
itself and so i'd say that's how my
views have changed drug gupta says your
he wants to know or she wants to know
your introduction with films and you're
interested in watching them now now i
used to i watch
virtually any movie now i used to be a
film snob as for my introduction to
films i
started off just like anyone else just
watching films never had a extreme
attraction to them still don't i just
watch them with my wife almost as
pastime to enjoy
with her
i'm i don't crave watching films i
actually enjoy creating more than i do
watching and i'll always have elijah
says hey kurt revulet here
i'm fascinated by people's upbringing
and was curious if you could give us a
rundown as to what it was like growing
up what were your parents like what were
some of the most significant moments of
your life
what was it like growing up well i grew
up in a somewhat tough neighborhood of
toronto
keep in mind tough neighborhood of
toronto that's in canada that means
a pleasant neighborhood in the states
let's see
so i grew up in a relatively tough
neighborhood in toronto called jane and
finch as for my parents
my parents are hard-working people
hard hard hard hard hard working people
they
they
worked like mad
they came from almost nothing my dad
especially my dad's and his brothers
slept on dirt in trinidad there were
nights where they slept on dirt
there were nights or times where they
ate
dirt they also ate the dirt they slept
on dirt they ate the dirt at times which
i think means that they were lacking in
a certain vitamin might be b12
it came from that to coming to toronto
bringing their family having kids
now i have this
sumptuous splendor of prosperity around
me
where i have a condo and i can speak
into a microphone and relay that to
hundreds or at least almost 100 people
who are watching
and they have nice clothing and i have
it's just it's just wonderful
i'm not a tenth of my parents
in terms of diligence
as for what were the significant moments
of my life getting
married getting married was a
huge moment for me
i love my wife
screening my first film was also a huge
moment for me
it's screened at a place called the
toronto international film festival
lightbox
that's the tiff lightbox or the bell
tiff lightbox because it's owned by bell
media
that was a huge moment for me because it
was received
well although i wouldn't recommend
watching it now it's
anything that i've done that's more than
two years old i'm utterly embarrassed of
odd turly in fact anything that's more
than six months old i
i cringe at so this is five years old
and or six years old i wouldn't look at
it if i was you i'll take some questions
now from the
chat
did i ever take peterson's classes at u
of t no
didn't know about him okay so this
person says you said in the orchards
interview that he was the smartest one
of the smartest if not the smartest then
who is the smartest he is he's the
smartest person that i've interviewed i
believe what did my mother and father do
to earn this type of wealth they just
kept working my mom worked at a factory
job like a hard labor factory job my dad
at like 35
got an undergrad degree when he couldn't
even understand the teachers
because he not that trinidad is
different than english but it is a
different kind of english he would have
to write all the words that the teacher
said
and he even wrote down the jokes and he
didn't know what were jokes and what
weren't jokes because he couldn't
comprehend it particularly well and he
would reread and re he basically
memorized different textbooks
because that was the only way he could
learn
they tell you don't memorize but
memorizing is actually i think that's a
i think that's a disservice that our
culture has done by saying you shouldn't
memorize what you can easily look up and
in some sense that's true but there is a
case to be made for memorization having
it within your working memory or at
least within your the capacity of your
working memory with facility is of great
use so my dad at 35 he said he was
humiliated because people were 18 year
olds in his classes but and at times he
would even sleep in a car because he had
to drive far and he couldn't drive back
he would sleep in his car go to classes
just to get a degree at around 35 36
years old just so that he can get
eventually a master so that he can
become a teacher
so my mom's back-breaking work almost
literally back-breaking work at a
factory and my dad's
intense devotion to scholarly accolades
so that he can be hired as a teacher
is what allowed for me to be in the
position that i'm in now elijah says can
you explain the most bizarre profound
experience that i've ever had whether
dreaming under the influence
psychedelics whatever it may be
no
i'm sorry elejay i cannot explain it
philip all says
do you think there could be another
coherent answer to the
question of why is there something
rather than nothing i think there could
be i don't see why there why there can't
be i just don't know what it would look
like and i don't have a clue as to what
it is philip s says i have a question
for you that's waited on me for some
time this is a
a problem a feeling of inadequacy and
uselessness when i think of someone
better than me i get the feeling that
i'm less than that person
there's something humiliating about the
fact that there's someone who's better
than me
and stands up higher in the hierarchy
and
as if they have power over me
are all humans equally worth
i think you mean to say are all humans
of equal worth
isn't it obvious that humans have
different degrees of power
he references spinoza
the thought of this makes me feel
inadequate and worthless especially
compared to some people like for example
noam chomsky he said
okay
there's a quote that i reference plenty
it's by hildegard de bingen she was a
medieval monk i believe
she said
in one of her writings
and pride germinated in the first angel
as
he could no longer comprehend the source
of his own light and through his own
radiance he said
he spoke to himself and said
i want to be master and want none above
me
and that one strikes me that one's
that one i think about
weekly maybe
there's such power there so i want none
above me is interesting
it equates
wanting no master
with lucifer so that is it's satanic
thinking to think that
i want none above me
i understand that this can be taken to
mean okay well let's justify slavery
then but that's not what it's saying
i mean you can interpret it like that
but i think that's as foolish as
interpreting the early comics of wonder
woman to be about sex when
that's not all they were about
i saw that in a movie once and that
reminded me of matt dillahunty
talking about that god likes human
barbecue it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
to say that it's such a simple-minded
reading of it and then
what's
what's false about it is that it's true
actually sorry what's tricky about it is
that it's true
but it's not all that's true in the same
way that
the early wonder woman
comics weren't just about sex
they also liberated many women or
were about female empowerment and so on
and to say it was just about someone in
in scantily clad clothing performing
bdsm
it's it's such a devaluing of what it is
it's such a
purposeful devaluing of what it is and i
see that in matt dillahunty's
interpretation of the bible
anyway
to get back to this question
i think that to believe that any human
is above you
or even below you is a sin i think that
to compare yourself to anyone in terms
of worth is a sin i think that for you
to think of yourself as more moral than
someone else is a sin
or even conversely then the converse has
to be the case that for you to think of
yourself as less moral is is a sin
though that one might
that one might be a lesser sin in the
christian doctrine there's a huge
emphasis and i'm sorry in the
judeo-christian doctrine there's a huge
emphasis that there's a nugget of
divinity at the core of each person and
that they're all equally
they're all equally inviolable
which means that
you are of no less worth than jeff
basil's now see this is
this is what materialism
does materialism is
the philosophy as well as the as well as
being materialistic but let's talk about
the philosophy
if you just look at the world through a
material
lens then jeff bezos is better than you
in some way because yes he has more
power and more money
but then that to me demonstrates the
lack
that demonstrates to me that there's
something lacking in pure materialism
see in christianity there's the cross
and i always wonder if one it symbolizes
quite a few
symbols are interesting because symbols
take into account maybe 100 phenomenon
and put it into one so this is just one
interpretation but i've always wondered
if
this level
the horizontal
sorry if i keep biting my mouth it's
because like i said i didn't sleep much
and my didn't drink enough water and so
my lips are dry
the horizontal may be the material level
and
the vertical maybe the spiritual
what it's saying is the spiritual the
material matters but also the spiritual
and it's where they intersect that
matters most and what's interesting is
in the cross
not in the olden days they were even but
now
you see the the material level as being
slightly higher what that means is that
this
the spiritual matters more
because it's higher on the spiritual
axis
i think it's a sin to think of the world
only through a materialistic sin sense
lens
but this is this is a tough question
and it's
in some sense all that matters is that
you're swimming you're swimming upwards
to go back to my
analogy of the diver
i think all that matters is that you're
swimming upward and you're trying to try
to swim upwards and make sure that each
day you can see yourself
as farther along than you were before
and that's easy absolutely easy for
anyone for me to say especially because
like i mentioned i have such i'm so
lucky with what i have and i'm in a
fantastic place in my life
and i know that if when i was depressed
which
i can get to a little bit about here if
you like philip this may
interest you
when i was 18 until maybe 26 or so i was
extremely extremely depressed even
suicidal i was so depressed
depressed from indolence from my own
indolence and from my own self-loathing
but i was
i was so depressed that i even
enumerated the different ways that i
could commit suicide in the pros and
cons of each
i lost many years of university to it i
got literal zeros in my classes because
i just didn't show up literal zeros my
undergrad which should have taken me
three to four years to complete ended up
taking me seven years
it wasn't until i mean there are many
factors that got me out of it but one of
them was to
one of them was akin to self-development
and not thinking of
i want to say not thinking of people as
better than myself but that's a human
quality i don't know of anyone who
some people will say yeah hey like i
don't think of this person as above me
or this person is below me but i'm
pretty sure that they are just unaware
of their own unconscious attitudes but
you can mitigate it
i think our society has done a huge
disservice with its emphasis on dating
dating people over and over and
i think that there's a profound
a profoundness to finding
one person one person and devoting
yourself to that person loyalty
and and loving saying i'm never leaving
you never never never never leaving you
no matter what i'm choosing you no
matter what no matter
no matter what other temptations there
are i choose you i choose you and then
that
and then that person has to do the same
to you and that's
in our culture that's called marriage
and there's something to that
because life is such a harsh
harsh harsh game it's such a harsh game
and if you can say
man it doesn't matter the world can be
against me the whole world can be
against me but if you're with me
then it's okay
as long as you're with me and i'm with
you it's okay
you also have to be close to god now god
can be whatever you
conceptualize it to be the universe or
so on i mean it then becomes so diluted
that it becomes meaningless but
what happens if some if you lose your
partner right then you've lost your only
hope so that means you have to have
something aside outside your partner
and that's why it's important that in a
marriage
the marriage ceremony is sanctified by
god because god is
always going to be there at least that's
what it says in the judeo-christian
texts
you have to have something that will
always be there so at least you can
always have god you have to always have
something always have your family let's
say so that the world can be against you
but you have them and that's all that
matters and i think that our society has
done
such a disservice by telling people that
what matters is for you to date and see
people and treat them and treat them
indispensably as if they're
as if they're
pieces of clothing that you try on and
return until you find the right fit
i think that's a horrible
i think that's a and i'm i'm saying this
because
there were years where i flandered and
was a lothario
let's say
indiscriminately seducing women
and i regret that
and it's not it's not fun for you to
look at your and i know this from
talking to people no matter what
whenever you're in a committed
relationship with whatever whoever it is
you're
you're hurt as much as you don't want to
say you're hurt by their past
and they're hurt by yours
it's not good
it's not fun
so i'd say stick to your
that's a tough question philip
stick to your conscience don't violate
your conscience never violate your
conscience stick by someone never
violate them never violate them and
that's all that matters and swim up
always swim up no matter what
jim carrey said that
he wishes everyone had 15 minutes of
fame because they would see how futile
it is now
that may be easy for him to say because
he already has it
but wouldn't it be a shame that
wouldn't it be a shame if you were led
by something false simply because you
told yourself it was true
so have a goal keep moving up the world
can be against you as long as you have
your loved ones and conversely look you
can have the world but not have your
loved ones and it's a horrible life it's
a meaningless one so that's not where
the meaning is and move toward where the
meaning is
finn says appreciate your videos
what is in your opinion the most suited
sentence to describe consciousness
i i don't know how to describe
consciousness without automatically
assuming it so there's one which is
consciousness is awareness consciousness
is what it's like to be but then what is
to be
well
who knows
da stell maine wants to know do you
think string theory is wrong
i think string theory may actually be
correct in a strange manner
for example i was talking with a
a professor or a former professor of
mathematics about
eric weinstein's
geometric unity as well as the monster
group which seems like it has nothing to
do with geometric unity but
there is a way to unify geometric unity
string theory as well as lisi's e8 via
the monster group and strings more
technically brains
so
i don't i don't know i don't know i'm
not one of those people like sabine
hostenfelder who make their abhorrence
of string theory known and develop a
following because of it
i don't know if string theory is correct
i used to be
somewhat of an arrogant little teenager
who barely understood string theory at
the time and would say yeah string
theory is foolish but
i'm not like that anymore okay frederick
guigui wants to know he just says ama
with robert sapolsky so i'm working on
it frederick
game changer says should one go against
his belief in order to not risk his own
financial security well-being and when
does persuasion become manipulation if
the intent is never selfish or bad
please watch your health and make sure
you get enough sleep and do not stress
even if the quality suffers the fastest
tortoise wins sending you lots of love
and then there's a couple emoticons okay
so the question is should you risk
financial insecurity in order to retain
your beliefs
well
i would say never violate your
conscience never never never always do
what you believe is right never lie
never never never lies especially in the
small cases especially in the small
cases because they're the easiest to lie
about
there's a time that i was
when i was doing videography there was a
client who said and i'm making up some
numbers but let's say he said we agreed
upon fifty two hundred dollars for a
video
so he said and this was over the phone
and he's like horse
video call whatever 5200 i said okay a
day later he said hey kurt what was that
number that i that you quoted me again
or that we agreed upon now there's one
option
that he was lying and
testing me but i didn't get that feeling
and let's assume it's not
i remember debating for an almost an
entire day
should i tell him 5400
because he doesn't remember and he has
he's he's a million a multi-millionaire
then i thought about it i thought about
it i thought about it and i thought
don't violate your conscience for two
hundred dollars kurt
don't corrupt your soul for two hundred
dollars
if the money is large it's easier to not
corrupt yourself because you can always
say to yourself well i can't ask for ten
thousand dollars extra because one
they'll find out but two maybe someone
else needs it and so on so it's the
small cases that matter because they're
harder the small cases are so minor as
to merit disregard
but you can't disregard
the blemishes on your soul and they
often take
they often
require
wiping clean with interest
keep in mind jesus didn't have financial
security by the way jesus didn't have fu
money and he still lived right same with
moses in fact moses i believe gave up
few money so it's a bit ridiculous when
i hear people say that what you need is
fu money no what you need is
principles
and you need to stick by them so it's
easy to be courageous when you have
tenure
in fact that's not courage it's
courageous to have to stand up for what
you believe in despite not having the
security behind you
in fact just so you know i left the
field of marketing i used to be a
marketer
i left the field of marketing
specifically because of this
i don't think it's ethical i think most
of marketing is unethical and i think
the people who are marketers know this
and they have to couch what they do in
language that
is so
self-deluded like value i'm adding value
adding you'll hear this over and over
this tony robbins-esque rhetoric that i
was wholly
supporting and a part of and
indoctrinated in although i wouldn't say
indoctrinated because i i allowed it to
take place as for the
persuasion and manipulation question i
would say
lay the truth out as best you can
and allow
whatever
occurs to occur
don't try to persuade anyone of anything
see this is extremely difficult because
there are some people who come to me for
advice personal people
and
they're so personal that i actually have
a stake in which way it goes
and i wanted
i used to do so much influencing that i
feel like i know the set of words that i
could say such that they would then
choose one outcome over the other but
then i have to tell myself that i don't
know what's best and they have i have to
just say what i think is true and listen
to them and let them come to their own
conclusions so that's another reason why
when i'm being interviewed for the
documentary people ask what am i
advocating for i'm not advocating for
anything because
i'm not trying to convince anyone of
anything i i don't think that's a
a great way to operate i think you
should just say what you think
and then let people incorporate that and
then they contribute some and then you
take some of that
i think that this whole
to advocate implies that you already
know the answer and that you know what's
better for the other person as well
that's why i would say that there's a
fine line between persuasion and
manipulation and i would advise against
it
don't breach a contract
with yourself or with god or with the
universe
don't violate yourself
okay and as for my health and my sleep
well that's tricky because
some of this takes quite a bit of work
and i often have to
sacrifice if i want to release with
quality frequently and grow this channel
it requires some amount of longanimity
which saps me of my
wall which which stops me slowly
but at some point soon i would like to
go on a one week full week vacation i
would love that that would be great my
wife would also love that would i
consider doing an interview with stephen
wolf from frederick yes i'm working on
it steven's steven's entire theory may
take two months
of work
jim carrey is crazy
i don't think you should i know you're
saying that somewhat flippantly and
frivolously but this is something else
that i feel adamantly about i don't like
i don't like to dismiss anyone as stupid
i don't like to dismiss anyone as crazy
i actually have an
adverse reaction to that one because
to be crazy is actually it's not
pleasant it's a and
and i also have an intimation that some
of what we think of as crazy people may
be on to something that's so
that's truthful that's so outside our
worldview that we consider them to be
crazy
i know so i i don't like this dismissal
of people by labeling them as crazy
this could be interesting you said
paul vander clay talked about fu money
and jesus
mm-hmm
yeah well i did talk to paul vander clay
it's on this channel
okay getting back game changer says what
drives you to find a toe and how much do
you entertain that a toe can be found in
this universe because if this universe
came from another one where there was a
singularity then how can we find a toe
well okay the what drives me to find a
toe is the same reason that drives
people to understand god or to
understand their place in the universe
or their purpose or where they're going
or their origins and i also happen to
like puzzles and i can't conceive of a
greater puzzle than this i mean the
riemann hypothesis is interesting when i
was 16 i thought that that's what i
would
go into university
solving geoffrey gefari says if i were
to suggest maybe make the transition
between each question a bit smoother so
that the guest can connect one answer
from another
this is not a question it's almost a
critique
but it's one that i hear brought up
quite frequently
so i thought i'd address it
see
this is almost a question about
my interview style to the degree that i
have one i always i'm surprised when
people say
that they
like my interview style or that they
no one is at least that abrupt to say i
hate your interview style so i mainly
get compliments but i'm sure
they do and they just don't leave
comments because they're actually nice
people and don't want to be rude
but either way i'm always surprised i'm
like i don't have a style i don't see
myself as having a particular style
once i was talking to desh who's the
producer of better left unsaid
one last promo for better left than said
it's a film that's releasing tomorrow i
directed it wrote it star in it it's
about when does the extreme left go what
constitutes the extreme left
politically speaking and you can see it
at better betterleftonsaidfilm.com
please buy it from there number one the
money goes more toward the filmmakers
than
if you were to get it from itunes
because they take a cut and number two
you get the director's version if you're
a fan of this channel you'll probably
like the director's version much more
okay so i was talking to desh
about one of my older videos it wasn't
doing too well i mean it had like
a 90
like ratio but that's actually low
it should be around 98 if you have a
decent following and so on
and i asked him was saying okay i'm
getting criticized and he said kurt it's
because you're mixing up different
interview styles
the audience doesn't know which frame to
interpret it's not the content itself
it's just that they don't know how to
interpret what you're doing so there's
three styles this is what desh was
telling me he said there's the joe rogan
conversational style of interview
there's the documentary style and that
documentary style is probably the one
that i had going in going into that
interview because it was for the
documentary and that one is where you
actually know the format of your
documentary and you're not trying to get
them to say a particular phrase but
you're trying to get them to say phrases
in a particular manner so that they're
easily editable and easily placeable in
the lacuna inside the editing
and then so there's the joe rogan
interview the documentary interview
and then there's the journalist type
interview and he said kurt you're mixing
up all three and people are getting
confused and then i said to him there's
a fourth that you're not considering
and that is office hours in fact i
wanted to rename this channel office
hours at one point because
in university there's something called
office hours where a professor just says
come in and ask me whatever you like you
have questions you have
misunderstandings and misapprehensions
come let's hammer them out that's what
theories of everything is it's office
hours i get this professor or this
luminary in for an hour to three hours
often i have questions i don't
understand particular aspects of their
theories so what i'm doing is i'm asking
them almost selfishly what i don't
understand and then the audience is
there
i'm almost indifferent to the audience i
know that sounds horrible but in a way
it's not because the audience tends to
be more engaged the more i'm engaged and
there's a facade of some people who ask
questions that they don't
care about
so i'm asking questions that i care
about and when
one gap has been filled then i just move
on to the next there's no need for me to
make a smooth transition because i don't
care about a smooth transition
i understand that the audience can often
feel disoriented but i'm also aware that
i have a fixed amount of time with the
person and this is primarily to
explicate toes this is about explicating
toes theories of everything
i want to make sure that this channel
gives some time to each potential theory
of everything when you talk to people
who say that they study theories of
everything
they actually don't and
the reason why i say that is that there
are maybe
30 to 50 academic toes and then
100 there are about 100 to 200
non-academic tools and when i
interview virtually every single person
and i ask them so what do you think
about this theory of everything or this
one or this one some of them they'll
know about and some of them they won't
have an opinion about because they've
never investigated it which to me how
can you claim that you have the correct
theory of everything if you haven't
conversed with the community and
understood what the options are the
alternatives
it's not simple it's absolutely not
simple
that's another reason why my interview
style if there's a style is that i get
into some of the academic
chaperone or the or the intricacies
because i need to mention what is so10
or
what is x-bar
structure in microtubules or sporadic
groups and so on
if this
podcast is geared towards solving a
problem which it is so if you are part
of this community
one of the ways that you can think about
this community to the degree there's a
community is that
what separates this podcast from others
is that other podcasts are mainly
conversational and they're just about
well i want to talk inspirational often
like tim ferriss and lex friedman
there's nothing wrong with them they're
brilliant brilliant of what they do i'm
not adept at what they do
but this is geared toward actually
solving a specific problem and the
problem of theories of everything so
that means there may be a final date to
it it may end in three years may end in
two years may end in ten years
there's a series my favorite series
that's a drama called breaking bad
one of the reasons it was so great
absolutely great was that they didn't
have it run past its prime
they had an end in mind from day one it
was
how do i get from here that is
i forget what vince gilligan called
walter white whatever some nerdy teacher
calling mr magoo to scarface that was
the journey so ours is unknown to
knowing or advancing a theory of
everything that's the goal
let's read some of the comments now
are you planning on getting your phd in
physics no no no no what i'm no there's
no
no no many reasons for no sorry
okay here's one reason if you could get
a phd in physics you have to solve a
particular problem and it has to be a
solvable problem this seems like an
intractable one you would not get
approved to be
you would not get approved if you said
what i want to do is survey the theories
of everything and make
an advance a potential new theory of
everything
that would not get any funding and
that's the way it works as well as you
have other departmental meetings when i
talked to i was talking to
jonathan gerrard of stephen wolfram
jonathan garage is a bright bright
bright fellow bright fellow
and he was saying i was telling him
we're just talking about what we do for
our days
he was saying well i had to do
so and so work and then i got to do some
research and i he asked me what i do and
i said pretty much i i researched all
day and he said that that's the dream
life
for
an academic research all day whatever
you want
so luckily luckily i'm so lucky that i
get to do that
do i plan to study physics in the future
i am studying physics
okay
thank you for calling me a hot man and a
and a
handsome man that's flattering i
appreciate that
have i grown more sympathetic to the
left after interviewing chomsky many
times grows more sympathetic to
virtually every side after interviewing
virtually every person i don't think
that one side see there's this phrase
that says
only the shallowest of mine can believe
that in great controversy one side is
mere folly and i tend to believe that i
don't think that the radical left quote
unquote is mere folly i don't think that
the alt right is mere folly as well
although that might get you banned for
saying i don't think that the
pro-socialists or the pro-capitalists
are mere folly
i think that many of them are misguided
i think that many of them are deluded i
think that many of them are
selfish i think that many of them are
lazy thinkers let's say
but who among us
are not scythe b i'm trying to decipher
your question i always have a difficult
time so please rewrite that if you don't
mind because i have to read quickly as i
want to get through this fairly fast i'm
only halfway done and it's been an hour
and a half and i imagine that
i'm going to lose some subscribers for
this but hopefully the ones that i
retain are the ones that are more
interested in theories of everything
okay glxl says why haven't you
interviewed jason reza
jor johnny yet do it let me put some
emoticons
i don't know this person grizzgrem says
i'm a random troll on the internet with
the theory of everything do you
plan on branching out past the
respectable demographic on your show
what he's referring to is right now i'm
interviewing primarily academics though
thomas campbell isn't one and bernardo
castro isn't one the answer to this is
yes
i actually encourage people to send me
pdfs and if you don't know where to send
me email you can
send me at a tow that is t-o-e at
indiefilmto.com
that email address is also in
the about page of this channel i believe
send me it there what i would like to do
is get two people because i takes me
quite some time to go through an entire
toe
i want to get two people
non-academic toes let's say
and get them to agree that i'm going to
critique this person and and this
person's going to critique me and kurt
you can moderate it and we're going to
live stream that on the toe clippings
channel the reason is that i don't want
to dilute the density of material on
this channel and
at the same time i do want to give an
audience to the people who are more
on the less rigorous side
griswold grim also says if your data
department reported all your interviews
and all the backups were lost which one
would you hope wasn't lost well i don't
know why if they reported it it was lost
but
let's just say was lost in the fire the
one that i would choose to be kept would
be bernardo castrops
any thoughts on chris langen's toe i'm
interviewing i mean yes i'm interviewing
him in late spring i believe or mid
spring
so watch out for that
what are your thoughts on wittgenstein's
ladder
the idea of propositions
that refute themselves
yeah yeah that was an interesting one he
said that
all of this was pretty much for you to
get up the ladder and then kick it away
when i believe it was in his tractatus
see wittgenstein is a super interesting
individual because he's heralded by the
new atheist rationalists as being on
their side but
he adamantly was not he actually
i think norman malcolm said
the religiosity that characterized
wittgenstein's later life surpassed even
those who consider themselves to be
religious
and wittgenstein said that he only he
believes that his work is only worth it
if the light shines from on high as well
as he said about box phrase he said bach
said
to the glory of the most high and let my
neighbors be benefited thereby
the most high god that is and
wittgenstein said i wish that
that could be said about my work so
wittenstein was deeply religious in fact
he said part of his work well he didn't
say this
in this in these words but he said that
part of his work was that religious
experience and consciousness and quality
and so on are so
outside linguistic expression that you
it's better to be silent about them
because you reduce them you and you
cause a curtailment of them by
speaking about them hans frankfurt says
i'm 36 and i
can i still learn mathematics that's
advanced and contribute something
meaningful so i would say hans that it
depends on your
aciduity and your iq so that is your
diligence and your intellect and that
you have more of a chance of
understanding the mathematics than you
do have of contributing to mathematics
unless what you if all you're concerned
about is contributing then go into a
burgeoning field find a new field
where
there are relatively few papers or it's
just extremely new
and research that
though i wouldn't recommend that because
then you're chasing new for newness sake
and i don't i don't i don't particularly
understand why
ivan goran says are you familiar with
general semantics of alfred
korusbiski nope
i'm not i'm familiar with some of
chomsky's work and to the degree that
it's a subset of chomsky's work or a
superset i don't know
ja524309 says i can't believe
this is he was referring to richard
orchards he said i can't believe you
asked richard butcher's one of my
questions from the comments in his
commutative algebra videos how did you
find that and did you just watch all his
videos well i'll say that i do my
research before speaking to people i do
my research second i learn and relearn
mathematics
almost on a daily basis so i watch
lectures many lectures online
in fact here's something you can let me
know if you're interested in this i was
thinking of live streaming my own study
sessions just to mitigate my own
proclivities to adhd and distractibility
as well as it's interesting to the
audience to study or to watch someone
study because then they study and
they're more motivated to do so
i realize that the toe clippings channel
has only 350 subscribers
it requires 1 000 subscribers in order
for me to live stream there which i just
found out today because i was trying to
live stream this there
so once we hit 1000 then i'll consider
doing more live streams on that channel
again as to not dilute the quality of
this one johann hedeval says
which one of your interviews made you
feel more energized directly afterward
and perhaps inspired you to try and
apply
well which ones made you more energized
afterward and which ones made you feel
tired okay virtually every single
interview makes me feel wired right
afterward though i generally go into
them extremely
habitudinous and
and
lacking of energy
and that's one because of my general
let's say dullness of mind but two
that's because
i'm often tired and fasting
directly before in an effort to study
for the interview it's difficult for me
to get sleep when i know a podcast is
coming up the next day because i'm
thinking about it thinking about it and
i have trouble i have
i have extreme trouble with my own mind
i'm uncomfortable with my own mind and
it's something i need to work on
it's something i struggle with
it's difficult to shut my mind off and
meditation does not help has not helped
i've tried it many many times
as for what drained me what interview
drained me there are two interviews that
actually drained me
mithuna's interview on looking glass
universe i was so tired going into it i
was just
falling falling taking everything from
me to just
to read and to pay attention to the word
she's saying a little bit of that is
happening right now that was not because
she was an insipid guest at all it was
because of my own innervatedness and
listlessness as for the other guest that
drained me thomas campbell
okay thomas bless his heart he is my
friend well
he i don't know if he would consider me
a friend i consider him a friend i hold
him with high regard but that man is
incapable of giving an answer that is
less than two minutes long
in fact often his answers would go up to
30 minutes long and i'm just thinking
time is money here tom i have 100
questions to get to
and i have a massage to get to and my
wife is coming home and i would like to
eat at some point and you've told me
this before and you're saying the same
sentiment in different words
50 times
can we please get to the point
so thomas was extremely draining
he speaks laboriously and it's
impossible for me to get a quick answer
out of him
but bless his heart
june 80s says number one you're a hot
dude thank you
i appreciate that number two what you do
is so unique thanks for the pursuit
i appreciate that
number three what are your views on
pineapple on pizza okay
so i assume this is a serious question i
let me think about this
i don't dislike it i actually like it
though i would never order it i'm not
snobbish when it comes to food in fact
i'm
indiscriminately voracious i'm the
opposite
i think i need to be a bit more snobbish
because i'll eat almost
i mean i don't eat lamb and
i don't eat any
i consider those to be
advanced animals for some reason in my
brain i consider them to be different a
different kind like lamb and
goat and duck and deer i don't eat those
i just i'm a simple man chicken
and
cows and pigs that's it even pigs i
don't i only like bacon
but uh but within that i eat virtually
anything
okay then he said or she said what is it
that you may have not done on your time
on earth that could leave you with one
regret on your deathbed
i imagine it's not spending enough time
with my parents
i'm selfish and
i could spend much more time with them
and it lifts their spirit like
mad it lifts their spirits especially my
mom especially during lockdown
but i don't visit as much as i could
and part of that is my own
i just treat them as an imposition on my
work
and i know they feel that and i don't
try to convey that and i try to even
hide that and i
even saying it right now i don't like to
say it i don't i don't even like to
admit it i feel like i'm admitting it
right now
but that's a part of me that is inside
me and i know that
if they were to die or if i was to die
that that would be a huge regret and i
and i still don't visit them
anywhere near as often as i could and
when i'm there i'm distracted i'm just
thinking about work mainly i'm almost
always thinking about work and i don't
they would say i'm a wonderful son they
would say i'm a wonderful wonderful son
but
i'm a well-behaved son
that's true and i think that's what they
mean when they say i'm a wonderful son
but i think that i'm not in many other
ways
that's my regret
that would be my regret and that is my
regret and
i'm working on it
or i hope that i'm working on it
light armanov
asks with regard to chomsky how do i
keep getting him on
he likes me chomsky happens to like me
for whatever reason at least he told me
so and i don't think chomsky is a liar
trump's i don't see chomsky is someone
who would be particularly polite to
someone that he dislikes
people despise that i like chomsky and
peterson because i'm apparently not
allowed to be a fan of both and that
brings me back to that quote about
only the shallowest of mines can think
that in great controversy one side is
mere folly
i think that's a foolish way of
thinking
i i don't i don't
i think that just demonstrates to me
that people have chosen their side their
side which has to do with what they've
identified with and that's why i have a
huge problem with identity and
identifying with some category identity
means sameness just so you know the
etymology of it look i'm i'm well
trained in my left brain that's a left
brain activity to see sameness and
categories
i'm i'm so well trained that i would say
i'm overly trained as a left hemispheric
person and i
need to
balance that with the uniqueness of the
right brain and see each as unique which
means you can't compare you can't
compare chomsky to peterson in a at
least not in a simple sense
and i have less sympathy for those who
are there is something in me that has
less sympathy for those who are on the
extreme left
that criticize in this manner than i do
for those that are on the extreme right
and the reason is that of personality
they
are on the left because they have high
openness that is a big five personality
trait
so i see them as like the right i see is
being closed-minded automatically so i
expect that from them but the extreme
left
the extreme left is so ardent for people
who are open-minded
which to me demonstrates that they have
this pre-ordained dogma that they're
following
and they're following it despite their
openness well plenty of that is what
they've been taught by universities but
i can't
but it but plenty of it is not
that's why it's important to never lie
never never never never lie you corrupt
your soul you corrupt your conscience
you violate it never never never lie
never lie never
never dishonor someone who
will never cheat on someone never lie
their horrible horrible horrible acts
horrible horrible acts okay my april
says you have an artistic side what do
you do besides filmmaking so i sing i
sing horribly and i play the guitar
horribly
it's more
grunge like
i
love art galleries i used to do stand-up
comedy
i used to write music i used to rap
i like writing screenplays
mario calabrese says what can change the
nature of man well what can change the
nature of man
i wouldn't say it's rational
argumentation
okay barfi man barfi man362 says please
talk about meaning equals intellect
intelligibility times value as well as
attention equals value structure of
beings also interest is about getting
more value than you put in
you and your channel are interesting
thank you appreciate that
this is my name sure i can play the
guitar for you but my wife is sleeping
right now
boris you asked if i tried l-theanine
yes doesn't help much ashwanganda it
doesn't help much gaba
i don't know what you mean by gaba if
you mean the if you mean gabapentin
fenubat
fanabot helps socially it helps you feel
disinhibited or uninhibited by the way i
have a letter wiki there's a website
called letter.wiki
with a conversation between me and desh
who is the producer of better left
unsaid and the
letter is all about my critique on
rationality so mario calabrese what can
change the nature of man i say not
rational argumentation and i can point
you to there to hear my views on
rationality which one person would i
like to interview most for the channel
so i'll give you a set
hofstetter is number one
daniel dennett
eminem
i would love to talk to eminem i would
love to talk to ed whitton i would love
to talk to terry tau hideo kojima video
game developer
the developers of rockstar
that is dan and sam hauser
i would love to talk to jonathan blow
he's the developer of braid and the
witness
i would love to talk to colin quinn he's
a comedian i consider him to be the
greatest comedian living right now even
of all time in my personal taste i don't
find i think some of these people who
say richard pryor was the funniest and
george carlin was the funniest
i don't know
george carlin never made me laugh he
makes the audience mainly clap in
agreement and often he astounds the
audience as to how he can memorize long
phrases but he never made me laugh and
that's mainly a function of time it's
that i grew up in a different era so he
probably was hilarious for his time
probably colin quinn will be
extremely lame for people 20 years from
now
so it's just a function of time much
like people love the old rappers i think
eminem is one of the best rappers if not
the best rapper ever
and i'm sorry obviously tupac is i'm not
a fan of biggie biggie had great flow
but tupac had a great heart and heart
like
heart like no one else almost each song
just makes you collapse
and this guy died when he was so young
holy moly so it's like tupac and eminem
but in terms of verbal acuity and
fluidity it's eminem by far i don't
think there's a contest
and some people who say that the rappers
from the 80s and 70s are the best
well it's more like they grew up with
those rappers and to them it was the
best for their time and it may be in the
same way that george carlin was the best
for his time
i think colin quinn is the best for our
time sean murray is someone else i'd
like to interview he's from hello games
a video game developer
sam harris i'd like to interview and i'd
also like to interview this guy named
cosmic skeptic i think his name is alex
he's not a dream guest because he's
within reach it's not a dream but nat
wants to know i'm interested to hear
your thoughts on philosophy and
education specifically pedagogy and the
curriculum pre-degree level
how
and to whom what age groups should
philosophy be taught and what broader
social problems might
be remedied if we had proper
philosophical education
here's my take on education i think that
what's in the stem fields as an
undergraduate
can be learned by any heist not any by
almost by
a
sufficiently gifted high schooler i
don't think there's anything in the
university undergraduate degree in the
stems that can
that cannot be learned by
a 17 year old personally i think that
philosophy is absolutely different
because it requires experience and it's
another reason why there's no such thing
as a
child prodigy in film
because you had to have gone through
life you had to have gone through
hopes and dreams and
places and pain and particularly pain
and philosophy requires that that's a
requisite as for the social problems i
wouldn't say that the social problems
are
a lack of philosophical understanding
per se but perhaps a lack of humility
that is
that people ardently claim that
whiteness is the number one enemy or
socialism is de facto incorrect
etc
it may be a lack of religious
orientation or a lack of commitment to
the good or a lack of being honorable in
one's private life no matter what
rather than a philosophical problem
it may be that and as for the last
question i need to think about that
am i thinking of having graham priest on
the show this is by no one knowing noah
yes it's confirmed but without a date
i need to work through his material that
may take a month it takes quite some
time to work through someone's material
i don't know why
you would say that jordan peterson is
delusional
what about jordan peterson is delusional
see i don't like this when people
dismiss people by saying oh he's obvious
someone recently said i elon musk is
obviously low iq
i said low iq elon musk why they said
because he doesn't see socialism as the
salute are you
well okay
i will
reserve
i
it's such a
such a simple minded thinking that says
that it's so simple-minded it's
absolutely not
easy to dismiss almost any intellectual
almost any intellectual
at least i don't think so
maybe i'm stupid
maybe i'm asinine freestyling i wasn't
that great at freestyling i could
but i never developed i was more
interested in writing the songs i had
about 50 songs in rap that i
deleted in a rage because i was beat up
one time during a battle with someone a
freestyle battle or a
rap battle where i insulted someone's
like anything is fair game when you're
rapping so i was 14 or so i insulted
someone's dead
cousin
which i'm thinking about it thought i
know somewhat foolish i actually didn't
insult them i just said
this was back when msn messenger was
around and they had statuses people
would put extra words
different than just just their name
someone said r.i.p let's say her name
was
sandra so they said rip sandra and he
would always put that rip sandra and i
saw that as virtue signaling because i
didn't see him as particularly caring
about his cousin so i said something
along the lines of that that saying go
and cry over your raps and then him and
a couple hoodlums came and
flipped me upside down in front of the
school from that day forward i said i'm
never rapping again i went home and i
deleted all my songs and then i started
listening to rock because i needed some
new music at the time
that's why i abandoned rap okay let's
get to this pac-man says what do you
think of the educational system hmm
does it help a majority of people think
like i said i don't think i think that
much of what's taught in school is
superfluous completely i think that you
know this because you probably don't
remember
99 95 of what you were taught in school
and louis ck once took his family his
two girls
when they were supposed to be in
elementary school out from school and
traveled for a half a semester or
semester or a full year or whatever it
may be and said that they got more
education from that than they got from
being in school and people were snarky
about that one reason they are is
because they're not able to do that for
their own child so they then tend to
repudiate others but i think it's
salutary i'm thinking if i have a kid
i'm thinking of
homeschooling him or her in a process
that peter gray calls unschooling now i
do have an interview with peter gray for
those of you who want to watch it it's
on the dracoma institute i'll leave a
link in the description it's not one
that's on this channel the problem then
becomes how do you socialize them
because they can easily become awkward
if you don't expose them to the
harshness of the flagicious peers
one option is to push them to their
limits of social discomfort another is
to develop or to cultivate a local group
of like-minded
unschoolers parents who are similarly
interested and then have our kid hang
out with them
as for education look
in math
i was watching a recent
lecture by richard orchards and he was
saying okay we're going to talk about
modular forms
now this is what a modular form is he
writes down the equation then he says
and now if someone says this is what a
modular form is it looks like if someone
had a contest for what is the strangest
equation you could come up with and then
chose one of them
i liked that because that's actually
what you're thinking when you look at
the equation for a modular form you're
thinking this is highly unmotivated
where did this come from why is this
useful
however if you look at wikipedia it's
removed from any
emotion from any commentary it's just
purely clinical
i understand that because it was modeled
after the encyclopedia it's called
wikipedia but a project of mine that i
would like to start
is a way of humanizing see i don't see
it as opinion versus editorial and
wikipedia would consider richard
borchard's comments to be opinion but i
don't see it as opinion i see it as
human
i see it as making math approachable and
i think that plenty people would
understand math and physics far greater
if there were little commentaries like
that and i don't know how to facilitate
that being in wikipedia maybe
wikipedia is not the right format but i
would like to cultivate a project in the
future that helps people learn math and
physics much more easily
as to what other elements or ingredients
it would take other than the occasional
sentences to how absurd an equation
seems
or where this is potentially going
whatever it may be i don't know and i'm
totally open to suggestions it's a
project that i have going on in the back
of my mind
paul marie says what is your background
in math and physics my background is a
specialist degree in math and physics
from the university of toronto and you
can look this up it's the hardest degree
that is math and physics i chose it
because as a high schooler you have to
choose it once you're in high school
i chose it because i always like doing
what's the hardest i
i remember once there was the
a puzzle called the hardest logic puzzle
in the world and i remember thinking
okay that one's i'm gonna solve that and
you know what i'm gonna solve that in my
head without writing so i remember it
took me about a month or so i wasn't
thinking about it
all the time constantly but it took me
about a month of thinking to try and
solve that problem in my head
i always liked challenges intellectual
challenges
so i took what is the hardest degree at
u of t it's the specialist degree of
math and physics the president of u of t
actually told me that was the hardest
degree i'm not saying i did well in it
in fact i had many zeros many many zeros
because i had major depression clinical
depression
and would just gain weight and
played video games
did nothing hated my life
horrible students horrible student
didn't go to class after first year not
one well a couple classes but
i didn't like going to classes i
despised going to classes i never took
notes even in high school
the reason why i didn't take notes was
because there was this lecture i watched
once where a professor was writing notes
and speaking and he was speaking what he
was saying was extremely important you
should have been taking notes about that
but people were only taking notes about
what was written on the board and then
the teacher was speaking and then he
started drawing a circle as he was
thinking and speaking and then people
drew the circle in their notebook and
then i thought okay i'm done i'm not
taking notes because obviously these
people who take notes are just followers
they're not actually processing the
information so let me listen to what the
professor is saying and actually
understand it and later i can go through
the textbook so i never stopped taking
notes from high school because of that
i wasn't a good student though by the
way okay you may wonder how is it that
if i wasn't a great student was i able
to finally get my degree well one is
that i'm great at studying for tests i
can
study for a test in two days or three
days just by going through the material
obviously i would forget it quite a few
days later but it was fairly easy for me
to study for tests still
it still is
peter nikolaov says oh man just do it
the make more than sure your subscribers
want to hear from you maybe not just
this q a maybe do an in-depth review on
what you think of toes
the toes that have been on your podcast
so again like i'm betting that the
innovation is going to come from
the periphery rather than the scholastic
center which is why i'm cultivating this
community it's not me this channel is
not just me even though my face is on it
maybe i'll start to
remove it more and more but the channel
is about us coming up with the theory of
everything or at least understanding the
different theories of everything and
then contributing
and perhaps at some point i'll do that
via live streams on the toe clippings
channel okay have i tried getting
roger's pen rolls on rishabs prashat
says
yes i've tried i can't get them on i
don't know how
i don't want to use brian keating is a
dear friend of mine i don't want to use
brian keating's connection for that
again it's distasteful sometimes to ask
your friends for connections
and i know i ask brian for plenty
and he's such a
good man he's a great man he's a jovial
man
he's a mensch if you
if you understand some yiddish i think
it's yiddish but i can't use them for
that i feel like that's stepping out of
my bounds rutger palakker says of all
you've read what book would you
recommend us to read beside girdle
escherbach uh beside girl esherbach
which is right there
master in his emissary if you're
it's a polarizing book people love it
people hate it the proportion of people
that love it are much greater than those
that hate it and those that hate it tend
to have already their worldview made up
and they say that's foolish that's
asinine that's imbecilic that's inane
out the gate and i just despise i don't
like that i don't see i used i
part of me not liking it is me not
liking myself because i used to be like
that to such a large degree
and i just see the arrogance in it
and then i see the arrogance of myself
and in my former self and i i cringe and
i i don't think it's good for the world
either way this will
master in his emissary will
discombobulate you in hopefully a
salubrious manner
ryan calling says what is love
to know love is to know god and i don't
know god
the greatest love i felt and still feel
is with my wife
it's an experience i can't articulate
into words and perhaps
there's a reason for that perhaps it's
destined to be like that
perhaps that's the point of it i don't
know i'm unsure ryan calling says ryan
colin which is also barfi man for those
of you who are listening barfi man wants
to know can you speak about the idea of
the attention economy is attention the
fundamental value of consciousness so
attention
changes or alters consciousness that
seems clear it obviously influences what
enters your perceptive field
your field of perception that is
that means that
in an
in a fascinating manner attention is
prior to consciousness which is
absolutely fascinating
and i don't think that there's much
attention placed on that aspect
now i do think that a missing ingredient
to consciousness may be an understanding
of attention
you know
in the same way that
some
thought that space time was fundamental
and then some thought that causality is
more fundamental than space time i
wonder if attention is more fundamental
than consciousness which
puts a huge hole in all those
non-duelists who think that
consciousness is the most fundamental
and perhaps that's another reason why
they don't like to talk about it ryan
collins says what are your thoughts on
solipsism my thoughts are that it's not
easily disproved by a rationalist
or empiricist account
and that to me like i haven't heard a
great critique as to why solipsism is
wrong from a rationalist it doesn't mean
it doesn't exist i haven't heard it
and that to me demonstrates a problem
with rationality or demonstrates the
solipsism is correct shar okay we're
getting we're nearing the end sharari
ronnie says what is your view on
religion and how is it changed after
rupert sheldrake i'll get to the chat
soon okay just a second i want to get
through some of these questions that
people have been asking me for quite
some time so how has my views on the
supernatural change from rupert
sheldrake and thomas campbell
rupert sheldrake it showed me that
there's a whole group of people who have
a disdain for what's supernatural
that edit on wikipedia
and that what you learn from wikipedia
isn't
the whole truth
sounds like it's obvious but it's
actually not that
these people who identify with being
skeptics aren't skeptics they're not
open-minded inquirers of what is
no matter what is whatever is will be
it seems like they have an idea of what
is and they're trying to disprove what
isn't or what and they have a conception
of what isn't
and they're also not willing to update
their conception of what an is is which
sounds like a bill clinton statement but
i'm talking more about ontology
so
these people who label themselves as
skeptics
demonstrate to me more they demonstrate
their axiomatic postulates
more than they demonstrate what's true
at least to me because
there is no supernatural maybe there is
no supernatural maybe it's all natural
but then you need to update what natural
is so maybe it is possible for people to
communicate psychically
i don't know it doesn't seem like it at
least from the evidence that i've seen
but or the non-evidence that i've seen
but i still have to look into it and i'm
willing to look into it and so many
skeptics have their mind made up as to
how is this wrong how is this wrong how
is this wrong and then if it's not wrong
then they'll say well there is something
wrong somewhere with the setup and i
just don't know what it is but you
clearly cheated
okay someone's saying what economic
system do we do you think we should have
i don't know that's a complicated
people think physics is complicated or
math is complicated but i think
economics and political theory is far
more complicated because the amount of
variables you have what's called
aggregatory feedback or at least i call
it that which means you get a yes or no
you get a ping did it work or did not
work but you have no idea which one of
the factors influenced it it's difficult
to do double-blind tests
sh money it's called sh money says hi
kurt i was pleasantly surprised to find
out you were trinidadian in the bernardo
castro interview which was your best i
think i think so as well thank you
although the ian mcgill chris interview
to me is pushing it
i myself was born in guyana so it's
great great to see someone from the west
indie community grapple with such topics
and do so thoughtfully as well just
wanted to say you're doing a really
great job thank you thank you thank you
anyways my question
are
my questions are what religion did you
grow up with were you born in trinidad
and
do you think it's important to honor
both systems of the east and the west
and then he says ps if you're ever in
queens i would love to grab a chat
grab a drink in the chat
the religion i grew up with was
christianity non-denomination but then
when i was eight i became an atheist
for reasons that i was
well
i was questioning the origins of the
universe and my brother who was studying
physics at the time told me about
quantum fluctuations and to me that
solved it and i remember
not vividly but almost vividly being at
home on my
bed looking at the ceiling
thinking that aha then that means that
there is no need for god
then i became
an arrogant atheist let's say which is
usually
the path one goes down they don't just
become a a huge a humble atheist let's
say
as for
east versus west and incorporating them
see this is super interesting super
super interesting because people will
say hey what we need is to incorporate
more of the east into the west
and they tend to be these people who are
high in openness again the personality
traits and you don't hear them
advocating much for the western approach
to be in the east so that's a huge gap
that i see
in their approach
which says that all religions are
equally true in some manner well
you're not advocating for the opposite
so to me it shows their bias all along
as well as when they say the types that
say that that they like
the eastern approaches
or that the eastern approaches need to
be integrated more with the
western ones they tend to focus almost
solely on the eastern ones and meditate
for three hours a day and say that all
is
illusory and there is no soul or if
there is one it's infinitely
being reborn
and
whatever it may be that are the
traditional dictums of the east
oh sorry decedarata of the east i
view it a bit differently i think that
that may be an approach incorporating
the east and to the west for people who
are high in openness and mostly those
who are watching are high in openness
you're most most likely in the 95th
percentile of openness
or 90th at least
but that doesn't mean that your approach
works for everyone and this is something
that i find so funny fascinating is that
people think what works for them should
work for everyone
and i tend to view it as
see the western tradition
and the eastern tradition for the
easterners the western tradition for now
is in our bones it's in the way that we
walk and we talk and we see and we
think
it's definitely in the way that we see
because your goals are influenced by you
and your culture as well as that's
influenced by the history of your
religion so the west judeo-christian so
it's inside you it's inside you to a
degree that you have no clue
it's in your bones it's in your sinew
and same with the east
and then to say that
well what we can do is take an eastern
approach and apply it to a westerner
well that to me is like saying you can
take a windows program and put it on a
mac or vice versa they may be the same
program solving the same
problem giving the same solution but you
can't run them
and that may be another reason why
people in the west find nihilism to be
so abhorrent because in the east well
they're like
they're okay with nihilism in in some
regard but in the west that's not us so
to give a
nihilistic eastern philosophy
it's horrible for people some people
momentarily it's freeing because if you
say there is no free will it's illusory
then that's
paradoxically freeing in some respect
because you're no longer
self-flagellating and
self-mortifying
but in the long run you then dive into
an abyss
and it's and i don't think people take
that into account i think that people
think if it's a solution it's a solution
and we can run this program on any we
can emulate it anywhere it might not be
like that it might be but it might not
and i just
well
as for the offer and getting a drink in
queens thank you i'm going back to the
questions which are almost complete now
okay what are your views on islam does
islam promote violence this person wants
to get me demonetized well i'll say this
that
it seems clear to me that some sects
or some
subsets of sects do promote violence it
also seems clear to me
that many don't it also seems clear to
me that their interpretations of islam
that are just as peaceful as any other
interpretation of any religion
then you get into the problem of what
defines islam
so this is tricky so see to me
this my view on it does islam promote
violence isn't more
sam harris is more observational or
operation actually it's more
observational in the sense that okay
let's look at the sum total of people
who identify with being
muslim and then let's see
how
readily are they willing to harm an
infidel and then let's judge the
religion based on that okay so what does
the religion
mean do we judge it by the followers of
the quran what is the definition of
islam is it the current followers of the
quran is it the current islamic leaders
and what they say much like catholicism
depends on the pope
what does it mean to follow the quran
that's an interesting question
okay so here's
here's one perspective
do you judge a religion by what the
majority of the followers say or do
see
old kurt let's say would say yes but
then kierkegaard came about
and kierkegaard went against the
conventions of christianity at the time
and was even critiqued for it but yet i
would say kierkegaard had a truer
understanding of christianity than the
majority of the christians at the time
so then that's interesting what the heck
does that mean that someone can have
someone can have access to a more true
or it can espouse or can
explicate or can
cultivate or materialize or elaborate on
a
christianity that's more true than what
the christians at the time were
engaged in
that's interesting
so then can one say the same about islam
see what we're getting to is a
definition of what does islam mean what
does christianity mean so i think these
questions of does islam promote violence
are more philosophical than
or at least you can take it practically
like you want to know if i have a muslim
friend are they more likely to harm me
than a christian friend or more likely
to blow up someone's own
you can take it practically like that
but i'm taking it philosophically what
does it mean to be a muslim what does it
mean to be a christian
it's not easy that's what i would say i
don't know
sid how many hours a day do you study do
you find it difficult studying math he
finds it difficult studying math for
more than four hours a day and he used
to be able to study for more than six
hours when he was at his most productive
so for me i study almost all the time i
wouldn't say it's math i try to study
for almost every waking hour that i can
unless i'm with my wife all i'm doing is
i'm with my wife or i'm studying working
in some way shape or form
i can study math if i'm
feeling absolutely productive i can
study it for 10 hours straight most of
the time is four hours and then there's
a
i have to switch tasks
mainly i have to switch tasks because i
have to see because i'm having problems
with my eyes now so i have to look at
objects that are more than one meter
away because i'm stuck in this condo i
gotta walk outside and see trees and so
on in buildings otherwise i'm
diminishing my eyesight and i feel it
eye strain each day worse and worse
especially yesterday especially
yesterday
okay someone says so euphoric 87 what do
you think led to your existential
curiosity and why do you think so many
people don't have an interest in
pondering the nature of things well most
people aren't high in openness so that's
why that's a as for my existential
curiosity i've had that since i was
eight like i mentioned what happened was
i asked my brother about the origins of
the universe and how can something come
from nothing and he mentioned quantum
fluctuations it's not a complete answer
but he mentioned it
and i remember thinking ah that's
interesting okay so
well ever since then i
became interested in physics and
and existential questions
okay which of your guests have you found
most compelling so far
bernardo castro and ian mcgillcrist
which interpretations of quantum
mechanics do you lean toward and prefer
have you tried any meditation if so how
have you found it okay i've tried many
meditations
many different types of meditation i'm
getting loopy here just so you know
i'm wearing thin
okay
i'm trying to hold on to the questions
one was the interpretation of quantum
mechanics and the meditation so
interpretations i don't lean toward any
i lean away from one which is many
worlds i lean away from that although
i'm not convinced that it's false i tend
to lean away from it mainly for a
psychological reason that i think the
reason for coming up with it has nothing
to do with physics but more has to do
with one abdicating one's
personal responsibility and what i mean
by that is it's the epitome of that
think about i tend to think that you're
special who you're listening to this
who's listening you listening to this is
you are special you can change the world
you can change the world for good you
can change the world for
evil
and i
do think the world centers around you in
some strange manner in the same way that
we're the center of the universe but
we're not
because there's many centers so it's as
if there's multiple centers and that's a
that's a strange paradox but i don't
know how to solve that antinomy but i
think it's true in some manner and i see
the many world's interpretation as being
the ultimate of the copernican statement
of you're not special you're not special
you're not special which by the way
copernicus was wrong you can make a
frame of reference where the earth is
still and the rest of the universe is
rotating around it with general
relativity quite easily so just so you
know there's no preferred way of
thinking about which one is spinning
around which even though he's venerated
as being the exemplar of science
prevailing over the church's dogma i see
the many world's interpretation as the
epitome of someone who wants to say that
you're not special
what's not special well you're a dust
mode amongst a cloud amongst a whole
hurricane that constitutes your galaxy
amongst many planets that constitute the
universe and so on
and then what's even less special than
that well there's many of them and none
are preferred
i think the world does revolve around
you in some manner though
i think that each lie that you say
replicates i think that each good act
you do replicates
it replicates it replicates it
replicates so do good as best you can do
good as best you can admit when you're
wrong as best you can
say sorry when you're sorry
as best you can
forget your ego be humble
love love love love
so
it sounds like i have not what i said
has nothing to do with physics
it has to do with psychology and that's
correct that's why i'm not saying that
many worlds is incorrect i'm saying i
lean away from it but i'm not wholly
convinced that it's incorrect i'm still
open to it cute kimus thank you so much
i don't know if you have a question
george scott says congrats kurt you can
see that we're getting toward then
because i'm at an s and this was sorted
alphabetically congrats kurt i have a
question for you
that pertains to your thoughts in
reality do you believe that there's only
matter or only mental states or
something in between
after interviewing so many intellectuals
how do you think about consciousness
okay so i'm unsure if there's only
matter i'm unsure if there are only
mental states i'm unsure of what mind or
matter is as well as okay as for the
my take on consciousness my take is is
that people who say that they have their
theory of consciousness and it's
in some ways i like it because i want to
know their theories but in some ways i
find it extremely organized let's say or
haughty haughty let's say there's 50
there's maybe 20 to 50 different
theories of consciousness and when i
bring it and i do and i bring this up
much like the theories of everything to
the physicist i bring up the theories of
consciousness to the individual guests
and i say can you comment to this can
comment on this king and often they
could say oh i can't comment on that one
because i don't know that one don't know
how can you say you have the correct one
if you don't know the rest
i don't understand that
there are competing theories that seem
to be self-consistent and you should at
least know all it's not that hard it
takes maybe two years or three years
the rmm says how do you manage to get
such famous thinkers to give you the
time of the day well i
do so with luck and persistence and each
feeds off the last so for example when i
got gnome pinker finally said yes
because pinker said no then i emailed
pinker again i said hey pinker i know
you said no but noam chomsky just came
on and it tended to do well i mean it
did fairly well so do you mind coming on
he said yes i can find some time for
that
okay throw away four four two one
i can't answer that question
it's
it's beyond my ability right now because
i'm losing my own trains of thought i'm
becoming witty
the whole point i'll read the question
to you and then maybe
i can try and answer it the whole
punching up and punching down i find a
lot of people like to make fun and bully
white people or any majority class when
the person on the receiving end is not
and the person on the receiving end is
not taken kindly to it i understand some
part of it but it feels like bullying
rude racist behavior
except they're justifying by saying
they're punching up and that doesn't
have social repercussions or they say it
doesn't i don't understand it should we
wait for something bad to happen
there's a quote that people will do
anything no matter how absurd in order
to avoid facing their own soul
i'll say that and i'll let you interpret
it as you will
voyager says kurt can you interview
commander
david fravor he's the guy who chased the
ufo off the coast of san diego and
fighter jet he was an extremely credible
witness yes i would love to interview
him however i don't have any questions
that lex didn't cover
lex did a wonderful interview with david
fravor and if you can think of any spots
that
are needing to be filled
or different angles please let me know
that's the main issue when people
request guests or famous guests what do
you want me to ask them i know sometimes
people just say well i want you to talk
to them yeah that's not helpful it's not
helpful for me because i already have a
list of almost maybe 200 people to talk
to
so please give help me out and give me
an angle someone says do you think you
can you can get a conversation with lex
friedman
i don't have any
any interesting information to give lex
i am not a great interviewer sorry
interviewee probably not interviewer
either but
lex is probably best getting someone
else if you're interested in seeing me
on lex
or on any platform it's best to then
mention me on the discord on his discord
on or on his youtube channel or on his
reddit
just mention me mention or on his
twitter feed because i know he reads
those so if you're interested then
that's the only way that i could see it
being done though i'd imagine that i
wouldn't have anything intelligent or
coherent to say
all right
i'll just answer the last question now
wolf winter says what is currently
stopping you from accepting idealism as
the best ontology specifically bernardo
castro's
form of it cheers
i have to understand it more
see if someone talks to me about it
i think i can give an explanation that
would be on par with not on par but i
would give an explanation that bernardo
would approve of but that's not enough i
need to understand it in the sense that
i have to live it to some degree and
incorporate it into my own thinking and
i haven't or i only have to a minor
degree
as well as i have to understand all the
different strains of consciousness
before i can come to a conclusion that's
what's stopping me see for conversations
like the ones that i engage in on this
channel as well as when you watch
debates or when i watch debates and so
on i don't think it's useful to think in
terms of an instant transformation but
instead to think in terms of
slow
a slow process of change a slow process
of a seed that's been planted seminal
if this was group theory if you can if
you're a mathematician
you understand group theory then each
conversation i have is like i've been
added a new generator
and time is the parameter
so it's almost like there's tiny chunks
tiny chinks in my armor my armored
vehicle that i used to pilot the world
and i see that this is
this needs mending this needs
abandoning this needs adding
this isn't where i thought it was i
thought it was stronger here and so on
and i find that my self-imposed
interdictions are unnecessary and that
my trumpeted freedoms are superfluous so
it's a
slog it's a slow process of doing and
undoing
i rearrange myself slowly and that's a
more effective way of describing what's
going on during these conversations
i think that's useful because people
want to say that this changed my life
and then someone asked you how did it
change your life and then you're at a
loss for words and then you feel like
well maybe it didn't change my life or
maybe i'm foolish on inarticulate or
maybe it's that it changed your life at
a small level right now that'll manifest
itself later
i think that's the better way to think
about it and as long as i'm oriented by
god or by
truth or by love
or all
i hope that i'm
i hope these conversations are changing
me for uh
for the good and hopefully changing
others for the good or more specifically
i hope that i hope that
thank you again thank you so much for
watching this i appreciate it i gotta
get going as you can tell i'm now
drained
if you want to support
more conversations like this then please
consider going to
patreon.com there is a custom pledge
people ask how can i donate more than
or less than 10 you can do a custom
pledge and it actually helps each dollar
helps
i
i hope that
what i've said is
coherent
and
sapid and copacetic
and if it's not then please
you can
message again and perhaps i'll do
another ama somewhat
shorter this time so that i'm not
struggling at the end of it
thank you so much
thank you
i'm going to watch the comment section
now for just a minute or two and then
i'm going to go
hydration thank you making sense
hydration is not something i have a
problem with at all actually i drink
perhaps too much water
there's more sleep that i have a
difficult time with
thank you thank you miss room nathan i
can't pronounce
this japanese character kanji character
name thank you
bo karina thank you jeron
jaren thank you
yvonne thank you
mundo
oh munda didn't say thank you but munda
thank you amen thank you
micro matt thank you dimitri thank you
dina thank you
barfy man thank you
amen thank you i'll look into it
try red light goggles yeah i have them
i've tried them
okay
thank you i gotta get going now thank
you bye bye
you